hey welcome back yeah
welcome to the Jim and Sam are Sam and
Jim however you choose to phrase it oh
that's so much fun
it is like we're a fluid show we really
are we kind of uh we take it as it comes
yeah how are you and rice Dallas Howard
is here what does that tiny little
beverage oh my gosh this is some coffee
it's it's called caveman nitro coffee it
has 250 milligrams of caffeine
how much is regular coffee has I don't
know I think it's like a hundred or
maybe last or something oh so I will
become increasingly hyper as I'm doing
this not like an endorsement although I
fully endorse you drink you drink energy
drinks I'm afraid to dress my stomach oh
no no no I just guess that's just a cute
little thing that little teeny little
can yeah like a little shot they're bad
for your tummy just energy to our energy
yeah I heard that energy drinks are like
that that you I'm going to be sued I was
like yeah no I'm maybe that's another
matter
right I'm looking boy you could die
eating anything right right
theoretically if you might enough of it
right the classics during too much water
right can you not explode there are
people who died it was a radio contest
to have a we uh we've ever you know yeah
whoever can hold the most water yeah and
then somebody and then somebody died
yeah yeah yeah I know that's that's real
now into the contest yeah I know that's
for real that's yeah yeah that happened
to radio like you can't do anymore of
like who can eat the most or who can
piss the most or who can do because
they're like no that lady died so yeah
nobody else is ever doing anything like
that yeah but it is it's kind of it's
it's sort of like this sociological
experiment a little bit it's like it's
that pressure of doing something live or
needing to perform and then you and then
you push yourself beyond what your body
can sustain right cuz in hindsight like
it probably feel like oh yeah I really
obviously shouldn't have done that yes
yes but now yeah but in that moment it
was I got everything's happening and I
want to get that we and every is
listening and I'm just going to keep
going I'm gonna win and yeah then you
die
yeah you're going for I wanted to ask
you to you're going back for a diploma
and I'm family not by people who do that
um well this has been going on for over
a decade
my I left school to start working and
what did you leave I dropped out of high
school so I'm hoping that you did - oh
no not high school no no no other
educated people there's a lot of
different ways to be educated but I it
was I think I finished like two and a
half years of school and so I've been
kind of like chugging awaited and and
I'm going to I'm going to come back so I
can actually do it properly do you
really feel like you didn't like I mean
I'm Jodie Foster went to college after
she was a huge star is it like a break
from being famous or you just feel
incomplete I'd understand could I never
once I kind of liked it I've had a good
life without high school but I some
people just go back and get finished the
education honestly it's it's it's not I
mean I like completing things I've got
kids I sort of like to be able to like
hold that over them you know but all
right because you can't tell them to go
to college right exactly exactly
although I probably won't tell them to
go to college so it's been awfully
expensive but I I think I just it's it's
it's whenever it helps it's like my
hobby it's fun it's it's um it's like
giving myself it's like the contest that
we were talking about in the radio
program creating a pressured
circumstance so that you're like forced
right to grow in a way or forced to
challenge yourself what are you learning
like what are you studying
um well interesting enough like I was
getting to drama I was getting my degree
in drama but then since then I've
actually focused more on on writing and
sociology so it might actually turn out
that I have more kids given it a degree
in drama so I feel like they should give
you kind of study abroad credits like
when you are in a whole bunch of movies
well it's um wasn't I tried yeah but but
I get it it's it's it's it's a different
it's a different thing and you can't
replace one thing with another and a
degree the degree is it so you should be
able to send a DVD of the help or
something and be like well I like a
moment well you actually you actually
have to show up in class that's really
well yeah
but my parents they very very
very very very very generously took care
of those first two and a half years of
college and in the going back I'm like
so we're going to restart this yeah
everything's perfect all right like what
a wait no are they in show business
my parents yeah my dad is okay I'm
kidding on the phone she's her father's
Ron Howard Oh that'll be fun why did you
not dream well you're like okay it's one
of those interviews I don't think they
have any idea how bad you want to throw
that little can of my favorite question
not one single bit no it's it's um yes
I'm not I'm not his identical twin so I
don't assume everyone but you grew up
and I grew up around it so for some it's
all very comfortable for you because you
saw all of it growing up so it's none of
this is new for you and it was well it's
kind of like the decide that's new for
me more is like the like the going to a
premiere like that kind of stuff right
into you as a kid but the being on a set
is is I mean that's yeah that does feel
like home and that and I only realize
that I kind of had that unique
relationship to it when when I was when
I did start working and I realized like
oh man in school we never actually we
were never on a set but that's that's
something kind of strange that can be
you know that they can give people a lot
of anxiety so I'm glad for that you were
on a set in a very like a really
uncomfortable moment you were in that
scene with Christian Bale when he had
that he was yelling at that a lighting
person because you hear this stuff and
people who've never been on a set don't
know that kind of stuff does happen
what is it without a lighting person or
what have happened well it's I mean it's
like my word should I get into this well
I think I think basically to describe it
is that there's that what what a lot of
people don't see in a movie set is that
there's a certain level of of kind of
lay intensity with which with which
actors approach scenes and and
circumstances and like in that
particular circumstance there was
actually a hurricane coming in we only
had a very short window to shoot a
really intense scene where I'm a
pregnant woman and I was actually was
ultimately cut out but I put a gun to my
head in the scene so it was you know it
was like emotion
Tyson's work yes yes and circumstances
were heightened yeah and and and there
had been side conversations that that
just became that became public and I and
so it's like it's kind of tricky with
with the movie because you also you know
there's Christian very very rightly
apologized profusely for that because
you know that's because he should and
but you also don't it's kind of why what
happens on a movie set stays on a movie
sets because it's like you you can't
really it's like this weird other
dimension of really what's happening if
you like a this is just one of these
things like I don't care people yelling
at each other in the radio no no yeah I
know that was that was that was a big
deal that you know and and and yeah that
was that was a big deal is that
something you like while you're acting
you have to keep that in the back of
your mind or keep your emotions in check
because you're like if I take the
emotion that I'm using here and then
just snap on somebody or something you
don't know who's recording you don't can
stuff that should stay on a movie set
like you were just saying doesn't what I
stay on a movie set anymore um no I
don't I don't think about that stuff but
it's also it's yeah I still you still
kind of like need to stay in that in
that bubble a little bit and just and
just like kind of trust that the process
is going to be what the process needs to
be in order and that everyone has an
understanding that it's that that it
needs to be a safe place that doesn't
mean that I'm condoning ever snapping at
somebody that rot that's not just a
matter if you don't need that in the
back of your head like you need to know
that yeah this is our space yes yes yes
exactly and and and again it's like
these things are these things are yeah
it kind of just extracting one moment
you always need context for any of these
kinds of things but you know it's also
wasn't okay if you put on you put on
what it was amazing you put on 30 pounds
to do the role in that one episode yeah
black mirror which was amazing did you
know that easy it's so easy what do you
put on the way
oh it was amazingly easy addicted to
scripts say that she was supposed to be
X amount of pounds or did you look at
angle ie this person should be heavier
well it's it's um the character's name
is Lacey pound and that was that's like
a part that that was sort of this
underlying element of the story and it
was sort of in the subtext that she that
she had you know that she was was
struggled with that as a kid and had had
an eating disorder and and that was like
really what plagued her so so when I
read it was really obvious I mean in the
first scene she's like running she's
like you know she's she's got this she's
in this cycle of sort of dieting and
self-loathing and all of that and not
feeling like she's there yet so it was
just um you know I was i that that was
just kind of what felt right for the for
the character and it felt right for the
holidays that came before my shooting it
felt really right during the holidays so
yeah yeah I'm going to do this mangi
McConaughey gained a bunch of weight for
gold right yeah was that something that
like is that something that he would
have chosen to do I just show up and be
like this is this character is kind of
down on his luck he's a bit of a
deadbeat he's not he probably shouldn't
have abs well you're like come on
Matthew McKenney one sees Matthew
McConaughey they're going to give that
guy break collection what it's I mean it
he did need to definitely change the way
that he looked and and it's similarly
for me it's sort of like you just start
preparing for the part and it feels
right and it starts to happen and you're
like I'm not gonna I'm not going to kind
of like stop it all right John right how
much did he put on you put on 45 pounds
oh he really fattened up I never buy
anything there's a ton of like a shirt
listings and it's all belly and like it
looks like a guy who just does an
exercise yeah yeah I mean I'm not sure
of it a lot a dress and it's right for
him yeah totally yeah when you're in the
movie takes place in the 80s so there's
like you have a couple different
variations of like 80s hair yes do you
have dress in movies when you see that's
going on are you like okay if I don't
play this right it becomes like a parody
of what it could be
um well you know what it's like we're
looking at this image right now is
Matthew
in character and I think I ride Cosette
and I saw Matthew and I was like okay I
can I can go a little bit bigger with
the hair a little bit larger with the
breasts that I'm here with the clothes
and so I think that that he kind of the
the he's in this amazing place exciting
place in his in his career right now
where he's he's taking a lot of risks
and he's being experimental and he's
just and you know and he's graduated
you're really necessarily show and I
have to say I would show it was so like
I'm shooting it was really soon that
wasn't a really intense moment oh yeah
and then in my childhood it's like he
went there and and as a result gave
everyone around him permission to go
there as well and that was really fun
will you bummed out though because like
he's such a sex symbol and I think you
do a movie with Matthew McConaughey but
you don't get like you know like you
know 1997 Connors I want to fatten up
for the role right now honestly I was I
was delighted because I think I don't
know it would have felt like wrong like
normal Matthew McConaughey like even
making eye contact with him where is
like this dude I was like all right like
I feel like I'm out of your league
brother this is awesome your husband
must have been thrilled with the choices
Matthew McConaughey man yeah yeah that's
that's I'm okay with that guy he didn't
he didn't feel as uncomfortable um
that's for sure no no you wouldn't
anyway how'd you meet him my hubby yeah
I met him at NYU I met him at school
when you were going back yeah no no I
mean I met what we've been doing for
like 16 years
oh okay you met him way back yeah yeah
boy I would what was your experience
with show business growing up because
you I read that like you didn't watch a
lot of TV or movies but it still seemed
like it was all around you like this
like Henry Winkler Godfather right Tom
Cruise is your babysitter is what the
internet says I wasn't there for it he
was just one of those like people on set
when there's lots of kids running around
the he's like I'll do backflips for them
like I'll entertain them I like yes so
um so he was just
he's not coming over your house in
Westchester metal it's no problem Ryan
definitely not no no um I think I it was
it was kind of what I was saying before
where was like I was really exposed to
what making movies looks like and that
was the fun like that was that like when
I would get grounded as a kid I would be
grounded from the set like I remember
when I was in fifth grade once my mom
grounded me from the set of far and away
and I was like you're ruining my life
like there was somehow I knew like I
just felt like I had to be there and and
when I did my first movie my first movie
was this movie two village and I
remember like I would I would rap like a
my day would end and I would ask the
director just in a case okay here like I
just I feel like I'm going in trouble we
liked it more then yeah exactly so I
think that that was kind of my
association with it and and the folks at
my that my parents are friends with are
still there even even though that
they're there people who are
recognizable they've been friends with
them since like high schools right like
my dad did the happy days starting at 16
and he started dating my mom at 16 so
like yeah he's like like it's like a
friend from when they were teenagers so
it's a lot of it's a lot of those kinds
of relationships and dynamics and
honestly it's it's like a lot of people
like I get questions like oh like
Hollywood like crazy Hollywood always
kind of stuff and I'm like what crazy
Hollywood like Howard's are like it's a
pretty folksy innocent situation don't
worry right he was I think he was a kid
though I mean your father was on set
since he was you know what eight years
older for yeah for so what it is did his
head so where does the strong foundation
like begin grandparents yeah
grandparents for sure my my granddad
he's still an actor he's 88 years old my
grandmother was an actress they they got
together and they're from Oklahoma and
my dad was born in Oklahoma and and they
would they didn't have child care and so
they would just bring my dad to
auditions that they had and he kind of
got discovered on one of those auditions
and my granddad in particular he was
really serious about making sure that
there were boundaries in place and that
my my dad and then
and eventually my uncle is well
understood that it was an adult job in
an adult world and there were certain
adult responsibilities and he didn't
have to participate at all if he didn't
want to so and they did things like they
had to maintain straight A's in order to
continue working as an actor because
they any went to public school in
Burbank and they knew that it would be
hard for him to maintain straight A's
while being a woman actor and so they
knew that he would only do it if he
really really wanted to right
what was your grandfather in was he in
anything I would know oh my god stage
actor yes yeah he was he's he originally
started in theater he was in Chinatown
he's been in like he's just if you
googled him like here if your phone is
on Google Rance Howard we know it's like
I know that we were aware those phone is
on Rance Howard Rance Howard and he was
a man my uncle like they gave me such a
great example of how to have a long
career as a character oh yeah yep that's
that's the recession oh yeah yeah what's
he been in looks he's been in a ton of
yeah I know it's very yeah that's
amazing yeah so and he's going strong
he's 88 and he's working and he's driven
in the same house in Burbank when you
get a role then so you come from like I
guess that and like you've seen how good
well maybe not because on one end you've
seen the career you can get as a
character actor but it's the same man
you look at your dad and it's like you
can also do really well when you're
defined by a role like I was going to
ask when you get a role like the help or
when you end up in a movie like Jurassic
world where there is this risk that
that's what you're going to be
associated with that's not a risk you're
finding that that's not a range that
means you've done something you've had
the chance to be a part of the creation
of a character that's resonated enjoy or
another and and that's that's like the
jackpot you love that yeah when you when
you when you like when people see me and
they say Oh miss hailey you know I'm
like I just feel this warmth inside of
my heart but really it is it's like
that's the fun of it that's the joy and
and to like
also seen seeing again examples of this
over and over again like my dad doesn't
cringe when someone says over UOP
already Cunningham like he's like yeah
you know like like Henry like Henry
loves that he was the Fonz right you
know like this is amazing so in an honor
he's a very lovely man isn't he yeah I
know he's probably the favorite guests
we've had on that art the fans respond
to he's just an Isis not alone either we
don't even have we don't have nice fan
know they're terrible nice men really
are they're awful people
but his his niceness like somehow
penetrates even that yeah over right yes
they find the non genuineness yet I mean
yes even if there's a hint of it yeah
and it's just not there right it's like
the Grinch with who's like it's like
their heart grows like it grows like
three sizes John saying that they just
you know there's just so so genuine to
know Henry Henry is the best it's like
yeah so have you ever seen him mad like
we had him we he was cursing last time
he was on but he wasn't angry he was
still in a good mood I'm sorry man I had
never seen him no right I've seen him
I've seen him when there's something
that he's like an idea or you know an
injustice or something like that he he
is you know he's serious he's focused
like he's he's not just like like a
cuddly adorable like sweetheart like I
mean he is but he is a really um I don't
know he's just he's just one of those
kind of sage individuals who just kind
of knows what's up you know in life and
everybody can feel it you just always
have that little bit of advice that
you're like oh that's really simple I
probably should have thought of it yeah
exactly yeah exactly yeah yeah you have
one minute they're saying yeah yeah yeah
we have one minute I mean everybody
should see this movie gold it's in
theaters next Friday January 27th do you
have are you the type of person who
stays proud of a project or associates
like that's that I feel like was home or
do you just move move move move move
from project to project well it's it's
both it's like III know my role as an
actor
you know like my role as an actor is
like you finish your job you just give
them everything that you could possibly
give them and then you let them do their
job and and sometimes the movie will
surprise you sometimes even the
performance will surprise you and and so
it's like you yeah I move on but I'm
also like I'm excited to see how how
everything turns out Wow and you had to
know in the help when there was [ __ ] in
the pie that that would resonate yeah I
guess one of the things that nobody's
going to let you forget that they were
[ __ ] in the pie right even before like
even before shooting it they're just
like oh my gosh I use the one who eats
to [ __ ] yeah everyone was really excited
about the devil the hell I remember I
remember like razza help was coming out
and I can it's a movie with the [ __ ] in
the pie I'm like I think you might have
missed the central man yes that is there
yeah that is there well thank you Bryce
Dallas Howard your delight
I see Howard on Twitter yes oh yes at
Bryce T Howard I didn't I couldn't get
Bryce Dallas Howard but that's just
that's right see Howard's falling pretty
much yeah way too much and the movie
gold is in theaters next Friday January
27th